[Music]
things are changing for Mariah Carey on
only our Carly Steele was backstage with
Mimi at the Hollywood Bowl last night in
yes who else was there
her boyfriend / dancer / creative
director Bryan Tanaka
it's another exclusive you had thrown
you arrived in this chair this year's
Queen diva had three costume changes 12
songs and one perfect man watching
backstage I gotta tell you Mariah and
Bryan are the real deal they weren't
even aware our cameras were rolling and
check it out he kisses her hand her
cheek and then one on the lips
this guy Bryan Tanaka how you guys doing
what do you love the most about touring
with me it's magical you know just doing
it together
the twins rockin row join Mariah on
stage and for the first time ro sang
if Miss Munroe is is able to sing that
maybe thus she will have a careers and
rocky so people on that boy that was his
neck then well he takes after his own
self is his own personality they went
and they ran is set on the throne
because they wanted to spit on the big
Chad I don't know it was kissing Mariah
and Lionel Richie's all the his tour and
September 5th of course
Lionel's rumored to be a new judge on
American Idol 2018 that's something Mimi
knows all about do you have any advice
for an I would say don't do it now I'm
only kidding if he wants to do it
that'll be great do you think Viki be I
think he'd be really good at it do you
think he just was trying to spoil me
when I went on her so you know that's
why the only reason I say that Mariah
also added she thinks Katy Perry will do
a heck of job but the judge's table
[Music]